[Music]
somewhere
[Music]
[Music]
all right
we're all going to tulsa oklahoma to see
stephen crowder and dave landau on may
14th
there's still a handful of tickets left
because these two decided to perform at
an ostentatious mega venue with 3 000
seats
sure you can buy tickets at
louderwithcrowder.com
tour but
looking at most of you i can say you
won't make the [ __ ] trip
because oklahoma only has room for real
cowboys
not want to be rednecks and
affliction t-shirts and
rhinestone [ __ ] woolly chaps with
undertones of
homosexuality
there's no room for fakes
i don't need any garth brooks attending
any more than i need hoodie and or his
[ __ ] blowfish
now those of you who are lucky enough to
make the trip
may not make it through the whole
performance
because these shows get rough
jokes about race gender sexual
orientation and all matters of subjects
deemed off limits by today's society
these shows are hard
they can be cruel
so if you think you're men or women
enough to make the trip to tulsa
oklahoma on may 14th by god i've warned
you
and if you do manage to make it through
the hour and a half program of
unacceptable taboo comedic body blows
the last thing i want to hear about is
your hurt [ __ ] feelings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
that's delicious guys get out of the map
tasty
minor attracted person so there's a lot
to look let me one thing lori love you
god bless you uh friend very very close
basically family he's just diagnosed
with uh breast cancer uh this morning
but we got it early good and uh i told
her we're gonna you know we're gonna lay
hands and pray and then but we're not
gonna be no shoulders yes
head and shoulders don't touch breasts
so i don't think that's what the song
says uh tulsa oklahoma may 14th you all
know now if you don't know now you know
today is a silver lining day yeah aside
from the uh it's international or
national asexuality day yes which you
know isn't a real thing but they say
that it is uh
we're going to be talking about the
oklahoma abortion law yeah and that's
not the only place where there have been
abortion uh restrictions as leftist
point twitter as we say you know
protections of life
uh there's a trend in this country and
there's a trend also with we just saw
georgia and their new carry laws as it
relates to the second amendment so
there's a lot of doom and gloom out
there and i know a lot of people think
the country is going the wrong direction
in every not in every facet
there really is
uh
there's there's a lot to be happy about
and i used to believe that tomorrow is
typically better than
today and today is better than yesterday
and of course the world has beat me up
and i don't know how much i always
believe that but i will say today is a
celebration aside of course from
asexuality day before i get to anything
else if this show is not on youtube you
don't see it and we don't let you know
that means well we've been suspended so
we are streaming live on rumble or on
mug club lot of credit.com club every
monday through thursday at 10 a.m
eastern don't let them
force us to lose touch nothing would
make me happier than all of you to go
over to mug club watch the additional
hour show today we play pokemon or
racial slur
i can't do that on youtube for obvious
reasons
or rumble if you want to watch the free
show nothing would make me happier than
for you to chat the ass of susan
wojcicki and everyone at youtube for the
rest of all time but you guys have to do
it first okay um
i guess my question how are you planning
to celebrate international asexuality
day
comment below you just gonna look in the
mirror and say
not good enough
probably not touching yourself yeah
probably no exactly yes ew not touching
somebody else not touching
i don't want anybody else when i think
of anything i don't touch myself that's
right
good little uh
you got a little bit of bobby womack in
there
asexuals on 110th street
no one looks good on 110th street not to
me
[Laughter]
all right gerald a is here how are you
sir i am well how are you i'm fine i
woke up i couldn't feel my fingers
because of the neck thing but you know
it has to get worse before it gets
better sometimes it just gets worse and
then you die must have paralysis yes
paralysis well i do have a paralegal
on staff ooh
so i just reached i realized i didn't
have my security blanket my pen so uh
i'm doing i'm doing well gerald i'm
really i'm happy about international
asexuality it's like passover for you
know delusional people and uh you know
him you love him he's actually going to
be uh this weekend april 8th at rialto
square theater in juliet indiana and
then april 9th at the what did i say
indiana damn it illinois sorry we were
just in indiana and then april 9th
genesee theater in waukegan illinois
go to light of color.com tour dave linda
how are you i'm good joey that's got a
nice prison i hear they do yes fine are
you playing the prison uh no
come on dave but let's go to prison that
movie was filmed there and they put out
a pamphlet the movie was based on
uh which was about uh prepare yourself
for prison and how not to get violated
yeah
don't go to church it's not really a
funny pamphlet but it is no and even the
pamphlet says like these are just
precautionary measures there's no
guarantee of success yeah oh there's
zero guarantees
in fact there's 100 chance you will be
violated but maybe this will there's 100
guaranteed success for the perpetrator
yeah oh yes absolutely that's that one's
underwritten yes this is just called
hope yes
they also had how to violate an inmate
for everyone else
it's a very rough breeze because we
would poison yourself
with hope
i read your book and now i only see
darkness
i didn't walk right for a week
uh
the mask pain pills do nothing okay i
couldn't wash out the taste of 50 men
[Laughter]
you merely became gay in these walls
i was raised by it
molded in it
i uh not one tooth remained
not one
yeah
the erection rises
so bane being
molested in prison that's it happened in
the movie all those guys dragged him
back down in the hole right and nobody
noticed that yeah exactly it's prison
what do you think they did give him a
high fives
he said what do you think would happen
if we all uh you know just uh gotten
here it would have been extremely
painful
for me
no
um slow news day but it's it's it's
international uh is it international
token or national asexuality
international asexuality oh okay so it's
a it's you know it's it crosses all the
countries yeah saudi arabia celebrates
by murdering them exactly
there's one guy there with a leather
stroke sharpening his sword yeah they
don't day today they don't have to have
wear a shirt or a flag we already know
yeah exactly who you are they just
assumption they just have like a
helicopter pad where they're just going
to be tossing people from the roof ah 5
000 tweets right
but it's at the top thanks twitter elon
musk get on that we have elon musk on
the show today bye
boom so okay first off lockdowns are
going crazy right now as you know in
china yeah
and uh
that's sad uh but luckily the brave
healthcare workers the real heroes are
out there
risking it all let's watch
oh no i hope the wagon's okay
ah the wagon was just carrying more
vials of viruses that's just a bunch of
bad sandwiches all over the street this
is what started the outbreak i can't see
who it was hey bring these to that lab
and your red wagon you know what we used
to transport viral stuff and the segway
that no longer is used anywhere since
the creator of segway killed himself on
a segway yeah which is the greatest
story ever he couldn't control his own
contraption which you know goes all of
two miles an hour it went off a cliff
maybe you don't ride so close to a cliff
well it almost it's almost like it was
intentional yeah that family's not
collecting the life insurance money put
it that way no they're like he invented
it no we can't pay out yeah
i couldn't stop are you serious oh
china china china i don't know why we
still allow them to be a world uh player
um okay you know they have the largest
outbreak right now since the beginning
of the pandemic in china yeah just half
chinese watched it happen no i
no i'm saying seriously 16 000 cases
yesterday that's the highest level
they've had actually the highest level
they've told us about
since the beginning of the pandemic
that's a little crazy how does that
happen i have no idea
i think numbers are just finally coming
out they're going to need to of course
they're going to need to set us back to
code red and bring back the ticker on on
cnn because ukraine rush has died down
this is just this is how the media don't
just buy into the daily media narrative
that's why we try and provide all of our
references at lightweightcredit.com so
you can go and do more research and on a
slow news day like today we'll actually
sort of give you a briefing on on a
little bit of the macro wins that are
taking place across this country not
everything is doom and gloom not
everything is bad you can tell
your parents that you know they can
watch nightly news they can watch the
fox news for a half hour it's not
something that you leave on 24 7 like a
morphine drip
it's fair point yeah it's true it's just
like background noise yeah they use it
just as you know white noise for sleep
yeah tired of hearing about war let's
talk about death from viruses yes it's
silver from bill devane yes exactly
your house now we're back to horror hey
i wouldn't be here if i thought this was
a scam yeah oh that's exactly why you're
here no thanks tom we're paying you to
tell people it's not a scam but we do
know it's a scam we had to get a trusted
face to make it believe tom adlib that
we didn't tell him yeah we didn't tell
him he was pretty adamant about it as a
matter of fact he kept saying in every
single line this isn't a scam or we said
tom you don't like you need to stop yeah
because this is a scam it's in your
contract tom are you taking that water
to your avocado farm yes no no
there's a shortage right this drought
not for me
all right so uh we're gonna go to this
we combine yesterday barack obama uh uh
former president barack obama returned
to the white house to uh help uh help
his old pal former vice president joe
biden uh expand healthcare so nice some
depressing scenes from the event which
the left claims is you know a victorious
moment i i don't know that i agree
brings us to this week in biden wait if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or trump and you ain't
black
[Music]
wait if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump then you
ain't black well at least we're
respected internationally again yes
happy grandparents day
most popular president in u.s history
guys remember that's what everyone said
but once donald at least the one thing
we can all agree upon is if when donald
trump is gone we'll be more respected
internationally well i'm really glad
that those asexuals have put us up a
notch in their uh
book he's not even respected in that
room no there's a room of people not
even looking at him he's the president
of the united states he could wander off
and no one cares the former vice
president of the united states yes
former vice president give him the
respect that's due well that's actually
what obama called him at that same uh
whatever you want to juncture yeah i
don't know you want you know how much he
was razzing him i bet if you just had a
mic i'm like hey joe you you're still
are you still [ __ ] your pants i'm
just joshing it you know
but no he really does
you should get get on your knees every
day and thank the lord above that that i
mean this is a miracle
it it
it's like chauncey gardner but in in
real life get on your knees like your
son does for crack
joking around joking around and i know
about crack i did it with uh
domestic terrorists back in college but
uh media you know sweep that under the
rug don't get all weeb up
he actually puts his hand on obama's
shoulder trying to get his attention for
an uncomfortable amount of time and
barack obama doesn't even look at him
because he knows the soft feel bony
hands yes
it can only be one of two things it's
either the angel of death yes or joe
biden yeah one of the others it's the
same cold feeling you get yes
you see joe going brook
barack and he doesn't turn
everyone's like hey i don't know if you
see he's calling if you just ignore him
long enough he'll forget about it go
away oh it's like a t-rex is his
vision's based on a movement
and kamal is just like if i stand next
to him and wave do i seem blacker yeah
oh am i more black she just immediately
starts laying down and over no no no no
no no no no don't open your legs that's
not she doesn't know what to do there
are cameras
don't you know i'm gay so not now not
now get off all fours come on allegedly
allegedly figuratively yeah literally so
oklahoma i have a lady man at home
man me and uh
my my high school uh sweetheart uh uh
michael you're like you mean michelle
whatever
come on over here mike
all right
so uh there's a still i wanna i wanna
spend some time on some good news a lot
of people think that there isn't good
news so i know the left is losing their
mind which usually it's a good sign it
doesn't all i don't want to just be
partisan but if the left is losing their
mind that's usually a good
sign that something is happening here
about which you should be thrilled so
yesterday the oklahoma house they passed
a full ban uh on abortion
which now heads to the governor's desk
it was past 70 to 14. um oh keep in mind
this is a state that has very lacks
marijuana laws too so it's not when
people think it's like this bastion of
just christian right-wing conservatism
it's it's a relatively sort of
libertarian state yeah and 70-14 that's
kind of a blowout yeah that is a blowout
so what does this do it makes a
performing abortion uh in uh oklahoma
the people who perform abortions right
makes it uh a felony and violators could
face up uh i think 10 years in prison
100 000 fine makes of course exceptions
and saving the life of the mother uh
this is important for people to note
because we used to run into this a lot
it changed my mind well what are you
saying you're saying you should jail all
women who have no no that's never been
the argument
it's never been the stance so just make
sure you cut that off with the past
because that's a go-to from the left and
this is also how you know that they're
not really learning what the other side
is saying they're trying to man you and
say you believe that women should be put
in prison never said that
i think that women are are often the
victims of abortionists as much not as
much as the the you know the murdered
child but uh they don't know a lot we
had someone unchanged my mind who you
know said that she'd had an abortion
and if you hadn't seen this i said well
okay uh i don't know if you know this
said she believed she was a she was a
christian you're gonna you're gonna meet
that kid one day if you believe in
heaven when you're gonna meet him one
day and she came back on the show a
couple weeks later and said i looked
into the science and uh you know you
were right and she'd become a pro i
think she might even be a i don't know
if she's a pro-life activist but she
certainly changed her stance because a
lot of women who get abortions who have
them performed they don't know they
believe what they've been told that it's
just a zygote they don't understand the
science of dna they haven't read a
biology textbook and of course this is
what happens on the left and they try
and say are you a biologist no i'm not
let's go to every biology book ever oh
life begins at fertilization there we go
all right well and dave you were talking
about the what was it colorado that just
passed well that's the problem is if you
think this exactly if you think this is
extremist
then that i mean it really is fighting
fire with fire because they just made it
legal to kill a nine-month-old baby
which that's just murdering a baby i
don't care what way you look at it
that's disgusting well when we were in
colorado undercovered an abortion clinic
there was a woman going in i think 34
weeks pregnant who's about to have an
abortion this is back then
that's it's just i don't understand how
that's legal
that's
here's the issue is people try and throw
out right these red herrings they say
what about rape and incest now let me
just clarify something here
let's change my mind
because we've done a lot of pro-life
change from we have the fetal chart uh
the goal of change my mind is is not to
score political points that's why it's a
lot longer than a televised debate the
goal is to sort of walk hand in hand
with someone and you're pulling
different directions and hopefully by
the end of it you're walking the same
way right so it requires a socratic
method requires asking people questions
that get them to rationalize their point
of view very different from a debate
you'll notice very you'll notice the
difference between how i handled a
rolling stone reporter journalist uh
monticelli versus how i will discuss uh
the issue with people on the street or
with students if i think it's an actual
discussion in good faith there's
something that i call and i've never
used this and changed my mind fastest
path to victory the most effective
argument possible in order to frame it
in it's like cutting off the ring in a
fight
it's very simple with the abortion
argument when they bring up rape and
incest it's a red herring so what about
rape and incest now i'm not saying that
rape and incest makes abortion morally
permissible but just say okay let's say
we make exceptions for rape and incest
would you ban all their abortions well
no then then don't use that you don't
care about rape and incest it's just
like when they say what about the kids
who were born here from illegal
immigrants the dreamers okay if we make
exceptions for them can we get rid of
sanctuary cities can we can we deport
violent felons who are overcrowding our
prisons who are here illegally well no
then don't say that it's about children
yeah eliminate it don't let them corner
you in what about rape and incest
just say okay let's say rape and incest
take it off the table everything else
that's not what it's about and
inevitably
you cannot find
a national a national player in the
democratic party
who will specify where abortion should
be limited no they can't do it it's up
until and including birth period
taxpayer funded if they had their way so
if you think this is extreme again again
keep in mind we're talking about
the people performing abortions
the doctors who know that they're ending
a life these are the people who are
being held accountable not the woman
is that clear that sounds good okay i
think that's a positive win and by the
way this all was on the back of texas
and we'll get to texas as well in a
second but they're saying because
texas's law was not struck down by the
supreme court that other states are now
going oh we can actually do this right
we've wanted to do this for a long time
we can actually do it yeah and the left
says what how do we do what you people
are cruel why aren't you speaking out
against colorado nine months well that's
just a woman's right to choose really
what happens in colorado if you try to
perform an abortion but the baby
actually is born which does happen by
the way and the doctor just says well we
will actually end that life because we
tried to end it in that mean like the
governor of virginia virginia as well
that's the conversation they're having
we'll just make the baby comfortable
while we make a decision or like we're
talking about barack obama look at the
infants born alive act in illinois i
think he was the only senator to vote no
which was uh
requiring hospitals to provide medical
care to babies who survived abortions
just like any other baby in the hospital
because now people say oh that wasn't an
issue it wasn't it was happening enough
that nurses and doctors were complaining
because babies were alive and they were
just being left to die
and he said no
barack obama that's a kind of evil
unbelievable it's the kind of evil that
a super villain from a you know from a
marvel movie
doesn't even have a form for yeah i just
can't wrap my head around how you can
get past the first trimester
and it would be a conversation i mean
come on ladies it's not picking a
restaurant make up your mind right
you got something you know what i mean
it's not ponderosa do you want to go to
bennigan's or planned parenthood which
one
either way someone's getting hit with an
orange oh blues busters so uh let me get
let me give you a couple of examples
here well first this obviously comes as
the country awaits in a supreme court
decision uh on dobbs versus jackson
uh women's health a lot of people
believe that this could potentially
overturn roby wait this is the complaint
from the left this get over turn roey
wait this could overturn roey weight
again don't let them get you off track
with this i think roe v wade is quite
what people think it is no it's not roe
v wade is not actually about a woman's
right to choose it really is a loophole
uh regarding privacy laws right right to
medical privacy that's really what the
case was about and that's why ruth bader
ginsburg said that she didn't think it
was good law and that she thought that
it made abortion protections actually
vulnerable
to future litigation in the future and
that's what we see right now it created
this arbitrary trimester framework which
is one of those things that i don't know
why um i think what is more accurate and
again you can comment below i would love
to hear your comments if you are not
pro life
let's say you're you're you're
pro-abortion you're pro-choice and to
whatever degree you are
where is it i i do not i've never heard
a consistent line
from people against it is it viability
okay well that changes and by the way
does that mean that a baby's a baby born
in lenox hill hospital in manhattan
their life is worth more than a baby
born in the hills of west virginia
because it's more viable due to modern
medical equipment is it geographically
based
is it based on a period in time
because a baby who was born 60 years ago
would not have lived right if they were
born prematurely as opposed to today
because of the medical attention that
can be provided
is it a heart
whose heart
are you stopping
when people say it's my body my choice
do you have 20 fingers do you have 20
toes if you're a woman do you have a
penis and i know it's a loaded question
right now with a swim meet champion but
used to be an easier argument the point
is now this is they want to blur all of
the lines trust the signs until the
science says this is a new living being
with an entirely different set of dna
it's autonomous from the mother and the
father everything has been determined
from eye color to hair color to male
pattern baldness to height to mental
health issues that all exists when you
end that life but the left isn't even
talking about that because if you look
at the states where the left have
unfettered control it is as extreme as
it gets like dave just brought up
colorado like virginia
by the way even liberal countries in
europe think it's extreme oh yeah there
used to be and they're godless heathens
no one's going to answer nine months is
the cut off right
the fact that the democrats well yeah
the fact that anybody would vote on that
is insane yeah yeah i'm not saying you
may believe that it's worse when you're
young when it's early you may believe
it's all the same that's fine whatever
you believe but the idea of killing a
nine that's a baby right that is a brand
new baby that is a
you a that's a crime six months
and well yes but any doctor who's
looking at a brand new baby in his life
that's not an abortion that's just
murdering a baby right as a doctor i
would just go oh i'm done right yeah
like i'm sorry
this isn't my job no absolutely and the
one thing i would say is yeah i think
it's important to look at the fact that
okay when they have unfettered control
the left this is where they go of course
nine months and including birth it
should i would ask that
you given that new information
reevaluate what it is that you thought
you knew about abortion right the idea
of safe legal and rare the idea because
the left would say well it's not
terminating a life they're now past that
argument where they say
sure but we don't care anyway because
they're they're too far in so just look
at the information look at the extreme
policies of pro-abortion states versus
the most extreme policy of a place like
oklahoma and tell me who you think the
fringe extremist is i would genuinely
love to hear your comment below um and
that also helps with the youtube
algorithm and it really chaps uh really
chap susan wojcicki's ass so
there are some victories here with
abortion a lot of states have passed uh
some abortion measures here that
restrict it so texas they restrict
abortion now up to six weeks uh the
florida legislature they passed a
15-week ban um idaho restricts abortions
down to uh i think it's six weeks i'm
not mistaken arizona's 15-week ban is uh
going to take effect if the supreme
court upholds the mississippi law which
it seems like it may uh wyoming's
complete ban on abortion basically
triggers
uh if roe v wade is overturned so these
are things you know people talk about
roe v wade and it comes down to do you
understand the law is roe v wade the law
and here's the thing you're seeing this
ban keeps liberals out of their time i
mean a lot of it is that if you want to
be you know sincere about it in my
opinion is if you look at they look at
california they look at new york they
don't want any of it you outlaw all
abortions liberals aren't coming to you
right democrats aren't coming to you
that's really really what they're doing
by pushing those laws right that's the
silver silver lining well there's a lot
of silver lining here uh
i think it's quite uh quite direct
you can call uh you can call me yukon
cornelius because there's just a lot of
silver i've always called you
i know that's what he calls it behind
your
back idiot econ cornelius it was weird
that he switched in the middle of the
special from gold to silver yeah like to
the less precious metal he's like i'm
not in a gold anymore silver silver
but yukon gold is worth a lot more than
silver oh you're still thinking about
the gold standard fiat courtesy
cobalt
nothing so
polling here's the thing too you see
this reflected in policy now i don't
usually like to go to polls as an
argument but this is important as sort
of an addendum to reflect the public
sentiment of policy pulling over the
last decade it shows us that the united
states is becoming distinctly more
pro-life surprisingly among younger
adults and i've always said this the
abortion argument right their territory
recedes the more that science advances
so they just have to deny science like
with covid yeah like with uh biological
males competing in women's sports
anything like bone density red blood
cell count testosterone all
i don't know
so
uh it's all about self it's all about
selfishness and just complete love of
self yeah when you get to that nine
month mark or really anything you know
like you said 34 weeks which is 36 weeks
it was i think it was 34 weeks or 32
weeks this person in uh in colorado yeah
i was you guys can go and watch
34 undercover and abortion it's 34 it's
the same as look competing in the female
sports when you're a guy it's
selfishness it's taking something away
from somebody else that's the bottom
line it's only giving a crap about you
right that's all it comes down to but
that guy is going to be polish that lady
is going to be polishing her trophy yes
that woman is going to polish a trophy
because we want to pretend that that's
okay yeah but it's not here's one thing
that's important that people need to
understand
is
i get it i was just speaking with
someone the other day who said you know
i was kind of i understood both sides of
the argument and i wanted to be
empathetic because you know what about
women who are victims of rape and incest
look we all get it we all understand
rape is absolutely horrible if you look
at
you look at how a conservatives
view
sentencing
we believe in harsher sentences we're
the ones who believe that we should have
law and order we're the ones who believe
that we need to get rid of this catch
and release program i don't think you
would be able to
hold it there's not a tenable position
to say that the left is harder on crime
okay certainly not now after defund the
police after the searching crime rates
what take your pick new york city
seattle portland los angeles right of
course they're not tough on crime just
look at look at the mayor here in new
york so
um
that being said uh i understand the
empathy of course your heart goes out to
women who are raped women who are the
victims of incest
but it doesn't mean that the left has a
corner on empathy and here's the thing
if you stand on any principles
you just have to accept this and this is
something that everyone out there
particularly a lot of young women
because women as jordan peterson has
discussed they want they're more
agreeable they they want to be
friendlier to people they want to be
understanding if you stand on principle
there's always going to be someone left
out in the cold the mo if you ever set a
line someone's going to be on the other
side of that line so you see this with a
change my mind and the biological males
competing in women's sports um
if you set a line
and a lot of other people were saying
well i don't think there should be a
line but they were setting a line saying
okay the line is how we've always
categorized sports by biology male
female
and they would say yeah but then we're
not affirming their gender and then that
that's being really mean and these
people might okay sure so you're saying
that we may leave out in the cold when
you set that line you feel bad for
people on either side of that line the
biological male transgender individuals
who want to compete with women
but what you don't understand is on the
other side of that line that people are
being victimized through your worldview
and what you want to enact as policy
is all women
all women who are competing for those
spots yes you're saying that their
feelings are more valid than every
single woman that competes in sports
right and the same thing here with
abortion when you say rape and incest
okay
i understand it you want to be
empathetic but if you set the line and
you say because of rape and incest all
abortion has to be legal okay so the
other side of that who's being
victimized
all of the babies in all of these states
where they have no doubt their life been
terminated after they are a life there's
no doubt as to uh whether it's a life
scientifically there's no doubt as to
whether to life morally now i draw my
line saying you just can't do it and
they say yeah but what about well on the
other side of that line is women who you
know they're going to be inconvenienced
or what about rape princess you're
talking about 0.1 and again go back to
the red herring it's not about that
because they want abortion to be legal
up until and including birth period if
you set a principle if you set a
principled line there is going to be
someone on the other side of that line
and you have to then gauge is that
person being legitimately victimized
by me
or
is that someone who disagrees
is that someone who just doesn't like
the policy who is being hurt the most
and look at that dividing line it
matters because everybody is setting a
line now here's another silver line i
was talking about polling
they're getting more uh pro-life 54 of
americans say that abortion goes against
their beliefs okay that seems pretty
broad 18 to 29 year olds are now more
likely to say that abortion should be
illegal in all circumstances wow
uh they're more likely than before
that's a big shift 2021 there was a
polling by stu and i get this is a more
conservative leaning uh organization but
there really are not a lot of polls out
there because i don't think that the
left wants to i don't think they're
gonna like these results hotshot uh
millennials in generation z this is a
2021 poll seven out of ten support
limiting abortion half supported banning
abortion after a heartbeat and 57
opposed roe v wade
and just to be clear the roe v wade
argument that we're hearing right now
all it does is send the decision back to
the states right that's it you want to
live in a state like dave like you said
you want to live in a state that that
provides unlimited abortion on demand
whatever you want go for it there are
states out there that will keep that and
think that they're righteous doing so
but they're also allowed to not allow it
yeah exactly so the thing that you're
fighting for is actually going against
your belief well they're fighting
against this with marijuana they're
saying well no the state should have the
right to say whether marijuana is legal
or not and the federal government has
had a law on the books it says it's not
and they're like oh no that that's
unbelievable but then when you get to
this issue they're like no no no states
can't be left
how in the world would you possibly
trust them with this right and i mean
really only the government has convinced
us that those are one and the same yeah
right you know because pot was legal
until you know the the alcohol business
yeah you know basically they had to
outlaw heroin baby cough syrup but
yeah it's
realistically like i still have a few
bottles i stuffed up in case of
emergency never know about that the
other day i want to get this bears opium
the first guy to have withdrawals
you don't have any cough syrup i'll do
stuff for it should i say it was two
cents i meant five dollars next thing
you know he's traveling with pt barnum
yeah but yeah
but i mean yeah they should take that
off the book federally you know they
absolutely should take that off the book
federally it's getting to i mean i
remember getting thrown against a car
for a dime bag and being arrested and
you're like really like now you can just
go into place and be like hey bud tender
i'd like some gummies
oh clearly you are in here for medical
attention yes yes i have anxiety can i
interest you in our newest strain
granddaddy purp rape yes oh yeah well
that's uh that sounds uh can you put in
a nice prescription bottle so i don't
feel like an addict yeah nothing uh
nothing helps anxiety like paranoia yes
nothing yeah no exactly like it helps
with my social anxiety really the 94 thc
vape pen it's like am i no longer
anxious or am i at the gates of hell i
don't know i loved pot but i never
thought it took my anxiety away
it's look and this is uh we can get i'm
telling lsd for the same thing
i just like to step into an acid trip of
terror yeah but you know he releases me
right now
my place wait a second wait a second are
there really gargoyles scratching at my
taint yeah or is this just the old
first acid dose in the morning uh side
effect
how's your head doing that doing what
just that how's your head doing it's
so uh
and by the way just to be clear i think
pretty much everyone here agrees that it
should not be federally banned or
underscore scheduled
scheduled substance list that being said
i'm just saying
don't claim that marijuana is medicine
for everything that ails you that's it
that's my only position of course no one
should be doing prison times an appetite
yes and it really can i fully agree with
that also cures aids just like uh oil of
oregano so here's another silver lining
this is this is we could be going to a
pro-life country remember a lot of
people said that's done they said the
moral side of conservatism is done it's
all about libertarianism nowadays i
can't tell you how many christian
sympathizing atheists i've run into so
many people who watch this program who
are not christians who weren't raised in
the church but who say i get it now i
understand how it's foundational to
western society because even i look
around and see this culture of
degeneracy and understand that it's not
the best place in which to raise my
children so we are seeing winds who
would have thought if you were to go
back and listen to all the consultants
in the republican party
that pro-life was a winning issue in a
lot of states another one no one would
have told you this uh georgia this just
happened this week their general
assembly passed constitutional carry uh
april first
so keep in mind when that sign into law
that means half of all states
will now recognize the right to carry a
concealed firearm a constitutional carry
or some kind of equivalent right to
carry well and this actually kind of
feeds into what we were talking about a
second ago about rape and incest right
so really specifically rape and how we
view women i want every single woman to
have the greatest equalizer possible a
gun yeah right so that you aren't a
victim of rape and i thought about it
too with planned parenthood like if
planned parenthood all the funding that
we sent to planned parenthood went away
because they're providing abortions they
stopped providing abortions all we
actually had them do is do mammograms
which they don't even do but they'll
start that service now right so let's
assume that's the case it's just a guy
in a cardboard box you cut out he's like
all right place them here yeah i would
spend every single dollar
that we had on planned parenthood right
now i would spend every single dollar on
making sure that people had
contraceptives to ending and
strengthening provisions for you know
getting rapists off the street making
sure they don't get back out into
society i would absolutely spend all of
that money on preventing the issues that
you say caused this in the first place
yeah solved done let's move on to the
next thing yeah and this is something
else too while we're talking about this
and this when i say half i mean half of
the country constitutional carry i mean
you don't have to go through a whole
concealed carry uh permit process which
people say shouldn't you have to have
training for a gun i have to get a
license for my car well a car is not a
constitutionally protected right you
need to understand that there's a
difference and there's a difference for
a reason but with women look i don't
care how strong you are i don't care how
capable you are the only equalizer
with a man who's trying is a firearm and
this is one example it's really hard to
get around when people talk about
transgender athletes competing in sports
there's only one sport well there are
several but basically the only sports
that exist where women can compete on
the same playing field as men regardless
of the hormones regardless of the
steroids or when you use say steroids i
say having lived with balls for 32 years
um shooting sports
women can be just as good at
at shooting sports as men to the point
where there were some organizations in
europe where they decided to separate
divisions because women were outplacing
men now not on a huge scale because
there still are far more male
competitors but it's something that you
can't get around if you're a leftist
because you have to look at all these
sports and say oh there are no
differences of course if you just go
through hormone replacement therapy for
a year and then the biological males are
dominating women
well what about shooting sports why is
it that women and men can compete in the
same playing field because it's a
mechanical advantage it really is an
equalizer it's not even close by the way
the same thing if you're a guy out there
and you're small even if you're a strong
guy guess what the only equalizer on a
guy with pcp is to carry a firearm when
people say oh if it only saves one life
well first off you support abortion up
until nine months and including birth
period second 500 000 to 3 million
defensive uses of firearms each year
when you're talking about low tens of
thousands of homicide deaths in this
country so
it is not even close as it relates to
amounts of lives saved by firearms as
opposed to those taken now when you also
of course take into account that most of
that crime occurs between gang on gang
violence yeah
the likelihood of you being the victim
of a gun crime in the united states is
so low
and the likelihood of you requiring a
firearm to protect your life limb or
your property or your loved ones is far
higher and you also have a far higher
chance of success statistically there's
no doubt about it like i say the numbers
are the numbers we can make inferences
as to why we can make inferences as to
well why when you take away suicide it's
20 to 30 000 you know firearm deaths
each year in this country why is that so
low compared to the around 2 million
defensive uses of firearms good we can
ask why
but we can only ask why if you
acknowledge that the numbers or the
numbers are the numbers left doesn't
want to talk about the numbers
everybody say something there gerald
well i was going to say uh that uh they
don't want to talk about the numbers
because they're really bad yes
and honestly the number you said 20 to
30 000 is actually that is for total so
i think 40 000 was a peak year including
suicide okay peak here and i think it
was about 16 000 were suicides the level
of the references available i'm going to
say usually it's around that 15 to 25
000 15 25 takes that out and a lot of
that is gang violence as well like you
see a lot of those things i i cannot
imagine holding a position where you
shouldn't have a firearm and then
somebody breaks into my home and i'm
like well hell
yeah look i'm a big guy like i'm a
strong guy but if two people come in if
three people come in like how am i going
to defend against that i can't there's
no way that i can do that so i want a
firearm to make sure because there's
always going to be evil people in the
world i don't care how many laws you
make criminals will have weapons and you
won't that is the end result period yeah
even i just like having a gun to play
russian roulette and win money yeah the
problem is you shouldn't be doing it
with a semi-automatic no that's just
suicide every single time there's a well
i believe it's fully loaded there's only
one chamber that's not right yeah and by
not he means it's also loaded yep so
i'll give the gun to everybody else
first and he also i don't he also has a
noose for just for safety yep well he
only plays it on his birthday yeah
that's right
he watched life as a house okay elon
musk this has been the hottest topic
this year yes uh elon musk's foray into
twitter ownership
uh and there's been a lot of speculation
of course like what is elon going to do
and he's tweeted you know he's
foreshadowed as to what he might do but
we don't want to uh simply speculate so
he's actually been nice enough to make
time uh mr elon musk to especially
actually after we did that segment with
the hodge twins on the tesla yeah turns
out he's a fan of the show and uh i
don't know if we if we have him but he's
agreed to call in and uh let us know
what his uh his plans hold on here with
the company
right now we've got it oh that's
fantastic i can't believe you had time
with all the board stuff oh okay uh mr
musk are you there sir
great elon uh thank you for being here
really we do appreciate it is it uh
so i want to make sure that i can
confirm this it's true that you're a
majority shareholder of twitter you have
9.5 of the uh the company stock now okay
and it was just announced yesterday that
um you've been appointed to the twitter
board of directors right
very formal
[Music]
yes interesting
what kind of ideas do you have for the
social media platform there mr musk
an explosion of ideas okay explosion of
ideas
like what
cat memes
implanted directly
into the cerebral cortex okay um i i
just what what would motivate you to um
let's put that on the side what motivate
you to pursue such a large ownership
role in in twitter was it um people a
lot of us right we're curious yeah joe
if it's is it your passion for free
speech for example yeah
uh
not so much
did you say not so much is though
but not so much okay
yeah but you sent a tweet out about it
crazy
i guess i just wanted what you humans
call
friends humans yeah well elon i don't
know if you know this twitter's
probably not the best place to make
friends someone but uh
it's almost nuts grimes yes
are you saying grimes brian are you
saying grimes or times crimes grimes oh
elon grimes yes that's your girlfriend
yes
she is a k5 impromptu i don't know what
that means so did you
wait did you build your girlfriend i
must go now
aspergers
i don't i don't
there's a fine line between genius
and insane yeah i think uh having a
normal conversation with him is
difficult yeah but he's still brilliant
and he still is kicking butt at twitter
already what a weird guy yeah but i mean
he knows what he's doing yeah you know
he does sounded just like him yeah look
can you
it's impossible to be that good at
something and not be a little weird okay
yeah that's true let's give them a break
yeah yeah
that's why there's all these pedophiles
in hollywood because they're such good
actors ah yeah that's that's not at all
where i was it's the
it's the afflict it's the cross to bear
of being a good director slash actor
slash producer casting director or um
yeah right and not to take you know
break the fourth wall or anything but
you know
real answers from actual interviews yeah
we're very fortunate
very fortunate to have the guest list
that we have yes so
here is uh
another story that we wanted tulsa
oklahoma may 14th expect more of that a
lot of credit.com tour
matt getz
uh yesterday and i know look before you
guys go into the matt getz sex
crime stuff i don't know if you've done
your research on that uh it's not what
you think it is well he's still not in
jail well also there's there's an
extortion plot going on and so we don't
have all the details but uh it should be
pretty cut and dry based on how they
presented it i don't is aaron why is
eric swalwell still uh above ground he
was banging a chinese spy right yes no
she was a chinese spy well listen he he
was a part of the the asexual group and
and then he found love right yes i mean
we can't love his love yeah how did he
not know though she's always talking to
an earpiece yes when they're making love
he's just like
he actually she's aiming her digital pen
at him yeah
he wanted to feel
important that was all it was can you
possibly get someone worse than him
i mean oh eric swalwell you tell me tell
me what is it you like in bed just like
what is it you like in international
defense policy yeah what does secrets do
you have an international yeah
it's probably like telling his friends
like spies are trying to bang me to get
information i've made it yes tell me
you're not doing it they think i know
they think i'm in the milk what was she
like this was her like getting into spy
school like the failure of it was this
time your country divided sick missile
test oh talk 30. all we found out about
him was he likes to fart on mike yes
that's all we got
great great job was that amazing how's
she above it
jeans
if you're going to do that on mike you
keep talking yeah you do not pause no
you just you just uh yeah you just claim
that white
you realize right now he's just with a
russian woman you're like this isn't
good
all right sorry uh cnn right now saying
just breaking news justice department oh
okay now they're bringing up some people
again who look like
using random can i ask a question can i
ask a question fbi had a target criminal
russian activity and new crackdown
unless that is happening in the united
states what in the hell are you talking
about hey we crack down on chinese spies
banging representatives maybe how about
the chinese spy crackdown i don't
understand this oh you want to crack me
down oh crack me down oh they just
seized the russian oligarch's yacht the
other day too and i'm sure there's putin
on his knees oh please they torpedo dan
bilzerian c-ray
bro
not in our sea house they took it what
are we doing where will i throw parties
on the water i i guarantee you if they
they just took out a russian oligarch's
yacht before the before the torpedo hit
it he was on his jet pack but
go to next yacht
that's true how many yachts they have
[Laughter]
you know what we need to do we need to
seize long tables that would bring us
exactly he's oh we have no tables they
wouldn't know what to do
running around like chickens with their
heads cut off
where do i have buttons where is yatai
parked right there yes all right i give
up you got yard what can i say you have
me okay hands are tied no wait i'm just
kidding i'm a private jet i leave now go
to look something time for more mass
graves yay
geez
tell uh tell your uh congressman who
bang chinese spy to not wait up yes so
uh matt getz he was uh um
in a heated exchange with defense
secretary lloyd austin and this was on
um
you probably saw from the left they're
trying to say look matt goetz just got
served here well this is where you don't
really see the whole context and i want
to be clear
he's questioning the wokeness at the
senior level in the military the social
engineering that's the term we should
really use the social engineering that's
taking place here we have matt getz
with defense secretary lloyd austin i
guess why did the national defense
university put out a statement again
this is funded by u.s taxpayers saying
in this talk mr piketty will argue that
the right answer
lies in ending western arrogance and
promoting a new emancipatory and
egalitarian horizon on a global scale a
new form of democratic and participatory
ecological and post-colonial socialism
so why would we invite people we don't
agree with to evangelize views and
values that we don't share
at the national defense university when
we should be learning strategy about how
to combat our enemies and make
assessments that are accurate and we do
learn a lot about strategy and about uh
about the military and about uh joint
force development
uh and so that is our focus in these uh
uh in these uh institutions no it's not
i don't know what the what the context
of this particular
uh or content of this particular mr
secretary i've shared with you the
context the context wasn't better
understand socialism so we can defeat it
the context wasn't learn about it so
that we can offer counter measures the
concept was that it's time for socialism
and the reason i know that's the context
is because the lecture was pulled from a
book written by thomas piketty entitled
time for socialist
it's the title oh that is of the book
that's really bad
when you put it that way
socialism time
uh
really not incognito with that no
it's not time for socialism uh i don't
know what that means
i think you do
yeah well we do talk about agree to
disagree stuff i thought it was ironic
yeah
don't you didn't you see my mustache
i also ride a bicycle where the front
wheel is a lot bigger than the back
wheel yeah that's what i do irony is my
thing
what i mean i'm only in the military
ironically yeah that's why i call that's
why i like to be called mr secretary yes
exactly it's ironic until that rachel
levine had to go screw it up yeah
so let me give you some other examples
of these mr mr the social engineering uh
initiatives under former vice president
joe biden that are taking place in the
military now let me preface this with
my bias
just so that you don't think i'm i'm you
know
painting this
presenting it through my lens because i
am yeah i believe the primary role
of the military
should be to uh
break [ __ ] and win fights
that's that's why i believe it exists to
protect us from threats and in doing so
you you know you win you go in and you
you beat people yeah you cause harm and
damage in order to secure peace for the
world because there are bad people who
you know and this is obviously what the
left believes because they're not asking
us to send uh noam chomsky books to
ukrainian soldiers
so you mean every military in the
history of the world yes what they have
based okay yeah yeah take your pick
ottoman military yeah the mongols well
the french are maybe the only exception
well they're they're the only ones who
go away surrender very quickly they go
in with their own standard issue white
flag their gun is just an acme prop
where it's just banging the little white
flag comes out never fired only dropped
once right yeah so um
and then they burned some lady at the
stake jonah i don't know what happened
chauvinism so uh let me read you some
examples of wokism of social engineering
in the military uh they have lectures on
white rage at west point um
how about we have encouragement uh
for rage not white rage but how about we
encourage our like i want you know can
we just can we give all of these
soldiers steroids and smelling salts and
just like go that way all right that's
what i want to see them yeah no rage
like outside of combat but when you get
into combat rage right yeah that white
rage is really gonna that's gonna the
training is gonna help when you go into
i don't know any other country we're
fighting yeah exactly
i mean you know unless we're unless
we're going to war with russia
yeah it's a team jersey yeah all right
guys we're going into the middle east
remember our white rage training yes
do not offend make sure you do not
offend we are going into the middle east
and uh in an act of good faith with
negotiated terms uh we will be shirts
they will be skins yes
so the navy also encouraged sailors to
read books on quote how to be
anti-racist
and sexual minorities in politics i
can't think of anything less relevant to
a successful fighting force than sexual
minorities in politics not even sure
what it means i'm a little confused i
don't know they're sitting like hey what
are you reading there i'm reading i'm
reading art of war what are you reading
i'm reading about some pansexual junior
senator nebraska yeah fascinating stuff
wow do you think that muslim beheading
that soldier is uh against us look i'm
not here to assume that he's a muslim
i would have no idea how dare you and i
don't know that he's murdering a woman
no it's definitely a woman she was
driving without permission
can you
can you tell me your pronouns combatant
i would like to be able to address you
properly yes prior to killing you yes my
pronouns are kabum
so uh the army by the way too another
example they were do they produce
physical fitness standards for women and
old people yeah because there shouldn't
be uh standard
old people yeah i don't even know why
they're in the military just like we're
creating pregnant we're creating
maternity suits for women in flight like
oh these these pregnant women they're
about ready to pop how are they gonna we
need they still need to get up there and
withstand the g-force of fighter jets
let's get them stretchy pence yes
very hot out here do you have a lighter
gun yeah oh lord is it hot
back in my day we didn't have these new
with these and we used to have the m1 it
was smaller it was more of a it was a
car being and now you have these large
rifles and it's just i won't be able to
i have my hip won't walk right for weeks
do we have any more vitamin c
yeah oh i need some fish oil oh boy i
hope you guys have stool sickener at the
mess hall how am i cold now
you just have a metamucil dispensary
that's all there is so they'll give you
an example i'm plugged up the leg tuck
was a test that was used uh which is
where you know you tuck your leg you're
hanging from a bar it was replaced with
a plank
in the military
not because it's more effective no
because women couldn't do it
we talked about this yeah women couldn't
do it and also soldiers with a doctor's
note can swim bike or row instead of the
run the two-mile run okay they can now
do a two and a half mile walk in other
words michael moore could qualify for
the united states military just time out
time out you're going to have to run
okay when the bullets start flying
you're not going to be able to hold up a
doctor's note and say can you please
provide a bicycle or something for me to
row in well this is a good example you
know we've talked about how affirmative
action what ends up happening is when
you have for example uh
disproportionately represented uh black
americans going to universities for
which they don't qualify they they score
lower than whites or asians on test
scores right but there's a certain quota
they have to meet it and so what ends up
happening is
you have black americans in some of
particularly stem fields dropping out at
a much much higher rate than the people
who qualified it uh qualified for it
upon entry
so that ends up hurting these guys
because they could have actually gone
into a program for which they would have
been more qualified they would have been
more equipped they would have been more
successful so in the name of equity what
you end up doing is hurting people
that's kind of like this only people
will actually physically die and those
are the people who are supposed to be
alive so they can stop you from dying so
you say well you know what let's let's
just lower these standards you don't
have to run
you can just walk for two and a half
miles for crying out two and a half mile
walk i do that with joe lewis every day
they'll be picked off really quickly in
combat at least you know who to hide
behind knowing the bullets are going
just get behind the you know the
pepperidge farms guy on a beach cruiser
just holding up mr french like yeah yes
[Laughter]
yeah michael moore could qualify just
get right behind him yeah just get right
behind him it's just this is the thing
with the gym
star wars and get inside
silver dicks upon their chest
these are these america's best so they
are now going into the military less
qualified and these people are more
likely to die guess what we should have
high standards we should have standards
that not only make it somewhat difficult
to enter the military but also an
aptitude test to see where they are most
quote how they can be most most
effective we don't want civilized people
this is the problem with being a
civilized society in soft times it
creates soft men soft women soft seas it
creates a soft society because you don't
understand what war is like and what is
required of people who go to work they
come back to pta they come back with
ptsd for a reason
because they were doing some hard stuff
you think
think about this for a second the people
who were coming back from world war ii
in vietnam had ptsd
what do you think is going to happen
with someone who has to who can't even
do a two-mile run
going into the military a trans a
pansexual 2.5 mile walkist going over to
the middle east or going into russia if
god forbid world war three happens how
do you think they're gonna come back and
be a functioning member of society when
they weren't even that upon leaving no
they're not the thing is they won't come
back you're going to train them to be
just good enough to go over there and
die yeah they're going to make the
segway guy in a cliff 2.5 mile canoeist
yes
i'm serious i mean you're just gonna
train them just to be good enough to go
over there and get in the way of a
bullet and that's not what this is for
we're training people to go over there
win the war as fast as they can and come
home right i'll be honest it's exactly
what it's for
there's no other outcome no no you can't
like that's absurd there and also you
know you mentioned vietnam and a lot of
other people we fight with a moral code
right a lot of the people we fight the
people don't have one they fight naked
too yeah
they're on pcp
right they're on or you know you look at
uh the nazis they were on actual like
methamphetamine or opiates and that's
what they have to do to get those guys
crammed into those submarines for four
day trips and they just didn't live they
didn't even make it they're like what
why you're not launching the missiles
he's dead against
blitzkrieg was like blitzed out of your
mind creek i'm not even kidding they
would give you drugs every single day to
keep up the pace yep it was the only way
and they were very clean too which was
weird and some kamikaze pilots still
missed i don't know how they do that
need to get better drugs axis of evil so
of course this happened speaking of
access of evil china you think they're
focused on this for crying out loud
china won't even allow muslim
shopkeepers to not sell cigarettes
they're not
they're not going to allow woke military
culture they're focused on expansion
they're focused on becoming more
effective more violent and speaking of
china gets uh pressed austin
on the issue and this is important
because this is the person who's
supposed to be the head of household
with the military uh didn't seem to
understand this one gets uh pressed uh
austin on the issue of military
technology well i mean i've also seen
that we're behind secretary we're behind
in hypersonics we've failed to deter
russia last year what are you what
you're saying we're behind in
hypersonics how do
who's the head in hypersonics how do you
how do you how do you how do you make
that assessment i don't know
i make that assessment because china is
yielding hypersonic weapon systems and
we are still developing them i make that
assessment because russia actually
by the way your own people brief us that
we are behind and that china is winning
are are you aware of the briefings we
get on hypersonics what do you mean my
own people
now let me just get this
i just want to make sure i get this can
you guys comment below and by the way
smash that like button if you can it
helps with the algorithm did
the united states secretary of defense
just ask with a
straight face and i mean that
figuratively not literally a straight
gay face
what do you mean we're behind
on hypersonics
did i hear that correctly i think so
yeah i also feel this isn't a
conversation that should be televised no
that's a good point it's really
terrifying yeah they're just like oh
yeah well you know what to answer the
questions let's go to geraldo with the
coordinates of that there we go all the
ukrainian bases he'll let you know we'll
be invading next yeah on her world
and hillbilly going into al capone's
doom i don't know why he still wants to
do it it's in his contract so let me ask
here's the thing matt gets asked him a
question this guy he's the secretary of
defense said well what are you saying he
was incredibly confused oh okay well
what would make matt goetz think that
we're behind on hypersonics well i've
seen some really alarming things going
on in china you know alarming as well in
russia but a little bit less so china's
made no bones about it i mean they've
actually rolled out some hypersonic
weapons and some of their military
parades have kind of shut off there they
even look fast we are behind we are
behind the chinese we are behind the
russians we took our foot off the gas we
allowed other nations to kind of in some
cases surge ahead by
spending a lot of money and building on
our work can someone get the secretary
of defense a discovery channel
subscription yes maybe yeah maybe that's
the issue maybe he should take a look at
the title that guy that just said
something there was a big sign behind
him that said raytheon don't don't be
confused by that he also had ceo of
raytheon what would he possibly know
about this well i don't know i mean that
would mean i'm not a doctor of
information right he's not a biologist
yeah no biologists yeah
so finally so if you didn't already uh
come to the conclusion that the
secretary of defense is inept this is
one thing if nothing else comes from
you know these two possibly four years
if former vice president biden makes it
i mean if he doesn't keep walking into
walls and [ __ ] um
or be
completely ignored by the secret service
just like lets him walk off like just
guys guys stay back stay back um if
now's the time if you've gotten nothing
else it's that the people who you often
think
are more knowledgeable because they're
in charge they're not they're just like
you they often know less and a lot of
you haven't had the experience or
haven't had the opportunity to get the
experience like i had when i was for
example i had fox news for four and a
half years and i would go up against
senators sitting senators so i would
have they just line me up i was 22 years
old like let's see what happens if this
kid argues with the senator
it dawned on me oh these people really
don't know yeah they don't know anything
now don't underestimate your opponent
but still
you should see that the people in power
the people who are the elite it doesn't
mean this is just a term that's given to
them it's a title that's given to them
say but for crying out loud you want
more more proof case in point pete
buddha judge is the secretary of
transportation
the former mayor you think he knows more
about transportation than any of you
but he's the authority and he gets to
decide he's the final say on
transportation policy as it relates to
the united states these are just people
who are given titles and positions they
have no business holding so when someone
tries to say to you are you a biologist
it's a totally irrelevant question it's
an appeal to authority fallacy and by
the way they're appealing to authorities
who can't even get their own story
straight the secretary of defense
doesn't know his thumb from his dick
pardon my language now getz
went after austin uh secretary of
defense austin for um letting our
enemies take advantage also of our lack
of leadership which of course with a
little bit of sting a little bit of
sting on that one toward austin i am
certainly aware of briefings that we
provide to congress but it's not just
the hypersonic it's all over the world
it's in taiwan where china's last year
flew more sorties than ever before it's
north korea on pace to shatter prior
records the number of missiles that they
that they are testing and so while
everyone else in the world seems to be
developing capabilities and being more
strategic we got time to embrace
critical race theory at west point to
embrace socialism at the national
defense university to do mandatory
pronoun training
you know it's it's again this is the
most capable the most combat credible
force in the world for now it's been and
it will be so uh going forward not if
you should be down this path to do that
not if we embrace socialism the fact
that you're embarrassed by your by your
country but no no no i'm embarrassed by
your leadership i am not embarrassed for
my country i wish we were listening to
you know what the that's you know that
is so
that is so disgraceful that you would
sit here and conflate your failures with
the failures of the uniformed service
members yeah really quickly i have some
points to make but uh him saying uh
disgraced in country meaning disgrace
you know feeling disappointment in the
leadership uh questioning me the
leadership secretary of defense austin
that's questioning your country this is
a very familiar attack we see it a lot
from the left where else have we seen it
very recently it's very dangerous chuck
because a lot of what you're seeing as
attacks on me quite frankly are attacks
on science
okay go with that now
where was the left when people would say
hey i'm against the war but i'm
pro-america yeah i didn't like it when
you would have people say that
conservatives say no if you if you don't
support the war then get that now there
are plenty of libertarians who are
against wars for example ron paul was a
non-interventionist i believe that he
loves the united states of america he
can go back from the founding fathers
through all different presidents who
support our military but try to use them
in a limited capacity this is something
that when the left they were anti-war on
everything now granted it was a little
bit tainted because they would try and
accuse all of our leaders of being war
criminals at that point are saying war
for oil even though they don't
understand supply and demand but the
point is they used to be able to claim
that i can be pro-america and i can be
pro-military without being pro-war
understood i actually think that that is
completely true yeah but where are they
now when they say and the fact that you
uh you know you you you uh don't have
any faith in the united states of
america that's not what he said
you're saying oh you hate america no
he's saying you're a dick he's saying
you're an unqualified incapable rube who
doesn't know how to lead a military or
the purpose of a military
it's not meant to be a social well
actually it is i should i should correct
myself the military is meant to be a
social experiment and that people become
a number
oh that's cruel that absolutely is
because no one person
is more important than the next person
outside of the established hierarchy
that's why we have titles that's why we
have
roles we have officers we have privates
we have colonel that's why we have
that's what establishes your value in
the realm of combat not your pronouns
not how you feel the military was
supposed to be a social experiment and
it always has been
and you now become a faceless nameless
number as part of a unit and now
just like society at large we think
we'll improve the mil we'll improve the
military by making it all about me me me
me me me oh my pronouns oh uh anti-white
uh race is a anti-colonialist white
sentiment as it relates to the officer's
quarters who gives a [ __ ]
i couldn't it could not be less relevant
you know who i want in the military i
want some leatherneck tobacco chewing
redneck who would have a rifle in his
hand anyway because he would be killing
something or poaching it that weekend to
feed his family only you switch the
hunting rifle with an m16 and you switch
the deer or elk out with a jihadi that's
who i want in the military yeah well
secretary austin makes one of the worst
arguments i've ever heard from a
secretary of defense and says we have
the most capable military in the world
when talking about a budget proposal
that they're putting forward that would
leave us with fewer than one million
people in our army for the first time in
decades and the point get gets is making
if your policies are enacted we will not
have
this kind of military in the future
that's the problem right that's what
we're here to talk about don't go back
and say well we have it right now of
course we do right now and again you you
create a dividing line right a
principled line so if it's if we're
actually the projections will be under 1
million people here's their argument the
left they say well we want to exp we
have lower military enrollment so we
want to expand this we want to be more
inclusive well guess what
you're doing the opposite what happens
is you're turning off the people who
would want to join the military because
they want to go there they want to serve
their country they want to the people
who used to join the military would be
people from patriotic states people who
felt a duty to country sometimes people
who wanted to have their university paid
for you're not having those people
anymore because now you are catering to
people who spent their entire life
hating the military they're going to
take out student loans anyways for some
gender studies course and what you are
doing is actually displacing the people
who are more qualified who can do a leg
tuck michael with people
who are now doing the plank can't do
pull-ups and get their feelings hurt if
you use the wrong pronouns so we've
reduced the numbers and we've increased
the percentage
of those numbers in the military uh to
those with you know mental
afflictions while we're on youtube there
we go afflictions yeah
not the shirt disturbances
what's wrong with the shirt
elvis was a good looking a lot
no no he's talking about affliction
shirts oh yeah not this gym it's just
the people that wear them not the shirts
just the stuff that i wear to peacock
bars here's a here's an idea instead of
spending money like hiring socialist
scholars at the the only the only reason
we should be hiring any socialist
scholars in the military is to you know
uh just tune up our our our firing wall
yes we need to study them yeah so the
torture learn what not to do our firing
squads need some practice we have any
one of those socialist scholars just
just you know bring them in no how about
how about uh how about united states
representatives banging chinese spies
this uh this uh this old uh the old
firing squad wall is looking a little uh
looking a little too polished pretty dry
these days yeah i want that looking like
a jackson pollock by noon
so
instead of spending tax dollars hiring
socialist scholars references available
how about i don't know we build like
more ships
so china has already surpassed the
united states uh in fleet size making it
the world's largest navy in china they
have 355 ships the united states has 294
ships by the 2030s they're expected to
have 460 ships
this year's navy budget plans to build
nine new ships great but decommissioned
24. so that's a negative yeah i'm not a
mathematician yeah but ships might come
in handy and if you ever did fight china
which i last checked is across the ocean
across the ocean and something about
china taiwan do you think you'll need
ships to get there i mean i don't know
we're doing so well with hypersonics
yeah somebody just stole all our yachts
oh that's what we're doing for our navy
we're bringing in
so i just gave you the silver lining
with guns of course with firearms with a
constitutional carry and with the
pro-life laws here's something i don't
want to be a downer but you know people
talk about how the roman empire crumbled
from within
we had the world we had the world's most
powerful military it wasn't even close
there's no reason that we ever should
have lost that lead and i'm not saying
that we've lost it now
but other people bad people just you
know if you believe in pronouns how
about not
torturing and killing and committing
genocide against you know
muslim uyghurs in china how about you
know not jailing people for uh you know
claiming some gender oddity like you
have in these islamic countries but
certainly china if you care about human
rights you would certainly have to agree
that china is pretty bad they're making
up ground there is no reason for the
united states to have conceded any
ground as the world's only
superpower we left the world's most
powerful superpower one century to
become the only one the next century
that's never happened throughout human
history
the only way we lose it is if we
squander it and we are and that's why
you need some leadership to get us back
and gear and it starts with a vision and
are willing to draw a principled line no
sorry you can't do push-ups can't be in
the military no sorry we're not going to
switch it to a lake we're not going to
switch it to a plank this isn't a yoga
class okay
this isn't soul cycle this is where you
shoot things and break [ __ ] bye that's
what we need to be doing uh now speaking
of of of what's going on in the military
this is more important to our really
yeah they celebrate the pelicans they
celebrate this and the marines yeah
great vigor yes yes
it's international asexuality day and
i'll be honest i didn't fully get it so
here to explain what it's like to be
sexually attracted to nothing
we have a local asexual uh and uh
official representative lester finley uh
thank you for joining us thank you for
joining us lester so i don't understand
this why are you uh asexual funny story
stephen i um it started after my fourth
sexual
arrest where i was chemically castrated
get out get out just i don't want this
get up but wait i came out this way for
your john hancock what's up is that you
need to sign this just please and
everyone no no no no no i don't want you
around here leave i don't know i don't
like you know what i'm gonna hurt him
youtube piss off i don't want him to see
this hate crime
you